[Musique]
en décembre dernier les entreprises le
bloc détiennent entre autres provigo et
weston la division boulangerie ont
reconnu avoir gonflé les prix de
certains pains pendant 14 ans en
compensation l'aube la offre à ses
clients floués une carte d'achat de 25 $
pour la réclamer il suffit de s'inscrire
sur leur site web
sachez par ailleurs que même si vous
réclamez le 25 dollars on ne pourra vous
empêcher en aucun cas de participer à un
éventuel recours collectif europe est
payant pour l'aube là il oblige les
clients floués à revenir dépensé dans
leur magasin et ils en profitent pour
accumuler données personnelles